[Musique]
la dynastie des ebooks
résumé des épisodes précédents la
métamorphose de maurice dopé par une
attaque reprenons la suite de ce grand
feuilleton la princesse la digibook
s'évertue à changer le style de mourad
et au moins je suis pas à l'aise comme
ça tu y fais comme les cas c'est une
petite cravate qui va changer sa vie
quand même v6 ou sochaux au nom au nom
du garde non reconnu par son chapeau et
justement faux pas contre eux
connaissent change un peu de look
le look oui kosako le look encore petit
robert look style art gothique dégaine
synonyme jeanne mas line renaud
voir page de 18 ans je vais ressembler à
ça mais non tu vas te faire un nouveau
style qui ajoute cette petite boucle
d'oreille voilà tu es superbe tu veux
pas continuer avec le mourant du bois
c'est pourri pour la chanson soit
pourrait t'appeler mourant non non non
pas moi c'est non l'espagnol n'en
sortirait bien molli d'ozil chapelle à
ce jour il n'a pas mal maureen aussi
j'appelle tu vas mettre beaucoup plus de
voiles étaient charmants tition je
chante à dieu
non j'ai pas mon truc de champion
du près le puy
[Applaudissements]
je chantais
[Musique]
pour fasciner l'armée d'agir qui me
désole
j'achète vous râlez mais s'était fait là
mesdames tombe organe formé mots
le champ
pour cette évasion gourmande de ce folie
qui nous attend
moi je
[Musique]
ola69 oui pour vous savez je suis le
super lot ce qu il est les photos d'eric
d'or de la sixième chaîne espagnole
oui j'ai entendu les petits moreno la
laine les chateurs qu'il est bien il est
bien mais il faudrait changer
complètement les loups coup et vous
savez nous allons surtout pour acheter
des produits américains
j'aurais cher à ce mandat là c'est la
vie ainsi des mots que moi le petit
espagnol c'était intéressant mais oui
américanisé moi tout ça et vous fait
confiance et merci beaucoup avait les
motos et les quads
[Musique]